save me as the Angeles annuities I'm
done on a 40 to 45
I see only diverse revenue stream - I
think the key to success was I don't
always have monetary ambitions
you can't mess with perfection but you
can moisturize it 41 years old I've seen
and tried mostly every product in
America I'm not familiar with the
product but I don't believe in a fault I
don't become partners where I want to
endorse it started drinking Arizona in
college only because for $0.99 you can
get a lot of liquid so we made the deal
with Arizona I thought it was a
no-brainer
we're off to a Macy's apparent ladies
live is just a affordable suit line big
guys we only have a couple places to go
I want to be able to go in there and buy
something off the right
you've got to have a Shaq back baby
yes the hire people spotted in greatest
leaders are the ones smart enough to
hire people smarter than I love frosted
flakes I would love to be on the cover
of that cereal but I only call him
getting his Wheaties and never really
ate Wheaties
you have money a lot of people say hey
invest in this box
see this box right here is gonna be the
next big flop you give me a million I
gave you ten million if you have to be
educated about the do your due diligence
you have to say okay a box is still in
are we going green a lot of guys they
just look at the monetary aspect it
messes them up I can't just tell a guy
invest always tell guys stay in school
get your education I think for me that
was the best thing to do